what's it like to play a classical event
after a difficult rapid and blitzing it
so normally it always comes at the end
when everyone's already played the
classical event it's a different feel
because a lot more games and I think for
some people it'll be pretty difficult to
adjust last year I noticed that a lot of
people who had not done well in the main
event actually seem to really enjoy that
up in blitz but I don't think the
emotions carry that easily into the
classical I mean classical everything's
gonna slows down a bit you play one game
a day and then it's a long tournament
you play the classical tournament you
you come with some opening ideas for
example and then you can just go to the
blades and of course use the same ideas
actually think it might raise the level
of classical but you know players are
gained some practice before the
classical so it usually that helps you
get a bit sharper you train your
tactical vision and accommodative vision
and that helps in classical I know from
experience that this rapid and blitz
events they take a lot of energy so all
the stress for five days it can be
really tough and then you have the
tournament in a classical game you only
have one game in that day and if you
make mistake it was very difficult to
come back in a blitz and rapid there are
a lot more games that day so after a
tough loss it's just much easier to
bounce back right away the very next
game oh that's gonna come down to
stamina in terms of one of the four of
us at the top has a really bad event in
the rapid and blitz it'll it'll be a
true test to try and come back in the
classical but hopefully that doesn't
happen at least for me we're not used to
this but but well we're all
professionals and we will try to play
well but it's not gonna be simple when
you play the classical and then you're
saying okay the tiring part is finished
now we'll have fun now you get to have
the fun and then play the serious event
so we'll see how it goes
last year I thought oh it's good that
they have the classical first but this
year I'm actually kind of looking
forward to the rapid Bloods